[Musique]
pendant que je gêne s'amuse avec les jbe
les shadoks en profite pour réorganiser
la tête
les shadoks pensait que la terre n'était
pas du tout organiser scientifiquement
tout était mélangé il y avait de la
terre dans l'eau il y avait de l'eau
dans la terre il y avait même de l'eau
dans l'est de los qui naturellement vous
retomber sur la tête quand on s'y
attendait le mois et ça il ne pouvait
pas l'admettre
[Musique]
les shadoks au début bien sûr avait
résolu tant bien que mal et
provisoirement le problème à l'aide
d'instruments spéciaux qui ont empêché
l'eau de tomber là où l'on ne voulait
pas mais ce n'était pas très rationnel
ce n'est que bien plus tard qu'il
inventait un parapluie beaucoup plus
perfectionnés qui permettait par tous
les temps de faire tomber l'eau quand on
voulait sur les haricots ou n'importe
quoi c'est ce qu'on appelait le
parapluie arrosoir ou parapluie tout le
temps mais ce n'était pas encore l'idéal
de même il trouve est excessivement
déplaisant compte ans promet ni non
seulement à la surface du globe
pompey tout d'abord à un trou qui n'a
rien à faire là non seulement les
projets mais aussi des trous plus ou
moins 1 dont les trous mixte et on fait
surtout les trous trop-plein une
montagne ou bac 2 gars tous ces
accidents laa ne serait pas arrivé qu'il
sait si la terre avait été rangé le plan
château d'organisation scientifique de
la terre était très simple une place
pour chaque chose et chaque chose à sa
place
d'abord le devin plombier été chargé de
deviner justement quoi arrêter quoi et
de mettre des pancartes pour qu'on sache
pour le reste transporter tous à émettre
les mêmes choses honnêtement
3 pour une équipe de déménageurs shadow
bien d'autres et franchement c'était un
jeu d'enfant la suite nous montrera que
ce n'était pas aussi simple que cela
[Musique]